meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
große ereignisse werfen ihre schatten
voraus es ist der deutsche web video
preis und hier ist das gewinner video
für die panasonic videozone reporter die
jetzt ausgewählt wurden aufgrund ihrer
bewerbungsvideos dies und die sie unter
den videos sorgen reporter aufruf
gepostet haben und zwar sind es kamerad
brille 9 lite neue und junge so ähnlich
irgendwie night light night i
abzuschalten es wäre es und der nächste
ist eine nasse den kenne ich eigentlich
als support aus frankfurt ist glaube ich
an island 07 und mister broadcast
yourself ingo access eigentlich dahinter
man eltern
eigentliche leute
das ist jetzt nicht meine idee der kanal
heißt so und niveau loks euch allen
herzlichen glückwunsch ich hoffe dass
alles klappt auch mit der anreise und so
weiter ihr kriegt jetzt mail und dann
freue ich mich euch zu sehen und kann
nur sagen es wird der hammer der
deutsche web video preis am 31 märz in
düsseldorf